I've watched someone dump red Tabasco on
pancakes before I feel like that might
be nice like the worst is when a
customer just interrupts you like hi my
name is dike oh yeah it's like okay and
then you just don't say anything you
just walk away and get the diet coke and
then I like coffee and you go if you
want cream and sugar and I like yeah
yeah like oh my god I'm so sorry that I
like I don't want to waste the cream if
you don't drink it there are certain
customers who think that you're their
only table snapper like if you look at
me like wherever you were on my priority
list you go into the bar you've now just
dropped to literally last place it's so
rude don't snap it somebody I'm not your
servant it just ruins the whole
experience yeah I'll get your diet coke
or they wave you down like a dog yeah
from here sometimes some people wave at
me and I'm like at another table I just
wave back I think I bet time do it or
they don't remember your name so they
say like hey you yeah that's very
disrespectful yeah I've had people
straight up me yell at me from across
the restaurant and I'm just like I
didn't hear you I'm gonna go do
something else when somebody orders
something how do you want to cook you
know well done Mary got a solo I asked
for well done it comes out well done
it's two world though you asked for it
that way so I'll remake it a little less
well done this time it's not cooked
enough
you kidding me you come into a place you
have allergies to certain things and
it's like where I come here you know
about people who've had gluten allergies
flour allergies bread allergies you come
into a pizza restaurant you know you
can't have flour you can't have gluten
can't have cheese I mean ice cubes it's
like watching the insane ways that
people eat their food but they also love
eating and showing you what's in their
mouth like though they'll stop eating
they'll pull you up in like law coffee
and you're like oh my god
I didn't want to see that you know
everyone always complains about how like
the server always comes up when my mouth
is full we're doing it on purpose
like I want to say like 8 times out of
10 we're doing it on purpose so that we
can just get the head nod that
everything's okay
and then run I'm all about families
going out and enjoying the time together
but if your kid is a maniac and a
disaster and throwing it all over places
you got spaghetti on the floor and
ketchup hanging from the ceiling I
understand it's our job to clean the
restaurant and stuff but at least pick
up after your kids don't let them create
mayhem and then just walk away be like
all right later and then not tip either
I always give the customers napkins when
I see that stuff like oh here you guys
go rule people man very impatient the
impatience thing with me is a big one
when people try and slip you money and
expect to get a table faster or if they
hit on you and it's like why why do you
think that I would like that but one guy
actually did slip me a 20 once and he
was like oh please my family's super
hungry and I was like I'm gonna keep
this cuz I recommend mum wage job but
the weight is not going to change
I've had people just literally screaming
at me I've been called a [ __ ] over eggs
and I just looked at her and went I'm
gonna go grab my manager shake I love
grabbing the manager I don't need to do
this anymore
I don't need to take this from you we
have a really big menu at my restaurant
they don't even open it they just sit
there and it's like ah like what's good
here it's like well we have a lot of
stuff if you want to go ahead and open
the menu they cool you over and you're
like busy is how and they're like do you
have nachos you have burgers it's like
yes it's under the burger section for
the menu
Haeju burgers do you have taco like what
do you have to drink it's like it's on
our beverage pages if you have PB I know
guys it's in front of you and I don't
know everybody I'm like you can read it
I'll be right back I just open the menu
please please God finally they decide to
read it but you have to stand there the
whole time while they go through
everything craft like has anyone ever oh
hey that too when you drop stuff at the
table and they ask you for something
else and you go back to get it and then
you come back and then they ask for
another thing and then you go back and
they're like oh also can I get the end
I'm like
is there anything else I can get you
before I leave the table and then all
their friends think of things too and
then you leave one more time and they're
like oh I'm so sorry we forgot salt and
pepper and I'm like put these salt and
peppers up your nose the customer comes
to the restaurant there's a wait for a
certain section it was nice out they
want to sit outside there there's a wait
outside but if you want you can come you
can sit inside and eat right away so say
it's an hour wait so they go walk around
come back in an hour and then go get
their table but then after the meal is
done they'll come and complain that they
want a discount on their check because
they had to wait so long
he knew the deal when you came in I told
you straight up it's gonna be in our way
you could have sat inside like I told
you and ate right away people love free
stuff people love to complain to get
free stuff I'm getting sweaty cuz I'm
getting angry
I work in Santa Monica it's the homeless
problem it's always like a homeless guy
at least once a month walking into our
restaurant also families that come in
who are feuding or not having a good
night and it just kind of translates
over to your job they're being really
loud and causing problems for other like
customers and stuff we've had couples
come in and break up at the table and
you're just like can I get you more
water this guy who was probably around
my age came in and he got really drunk
with all his friends
he said something really inappropriate
to me he's like oh it's really cold when
you you move the heater I was like sorry
we can't move and he was like can I be a
jackass I was like sorry it's my uniform
he's like can you sit on my face oh my
god I shooed him out and his friends
were like what's going on what's going
on I was like ah this is what he just
said to me any of a couple of
girlfriends and in the group and they
were like you kidding me like yeah he
got he got told and I was just like I'm
so sorry I'm so sorry and he kept
apologizing I was like dude like you
can't talk to people like that that's so
inappropriate it's not funny yeah people
people do it all the time
and they think she can get away with it
everyone should stop doing that
like you can talk to me but I don't
appreciate you like really outwardly
flirting with me when I'm trying to do
my job especially since I work behind a
bar as well I think guys you never
really know what their endgame is if
they're hitting on you from behind the
bar cuz you're like I clearly have a job
to do and then they get kind of angry
you're like not giving them all your
attention flirting back you look you
know no I wouldn't yeah when they go out
to eat they order everything they'll get
two appetizers they'll get the most
expensive courses and they'll get
dessert and they'll just run up a
[ __ ] tab what then
not tip I don't get it like if you
couldn't afford to spend all that but
you have to factor in the tip this is I
feel like a number one pet peeve it's
it's a given but don't go spending $300
if you can't tip bad tippers people who
tipped terribly after they put you do
the moves or when they leave a verbal
tip we like to call it verbal tips where
they like pat you on the shoulder and
they're like you did a great job we're
like you're the best server I ever had
and then they like don't leave very much
tip and you're like oh so you just that
to you was your tip no I know that I'm
good at my job I don't mean your
validation give me your money though
that that's what I need from you
typically to that food and for the time
that you spent that if you spend $100
and 30 minutes it's like I get it you
can tip me ten bucks whatever but if you
are there for three hours it's like you
should triple that at least exactly you
have to because you're taken away yeah
you're taking away all the money that we
could get in all the bad years that I've
experienced in the restaurant business I
have also met a lot of incredible people
as well which balance somehow balanced
out all of the [ __ ] as a customer
just be polite and I will be playback
and it makes our job more fun if you get
to know us and let us get to know you
and not in a flirty way I have made the
most incredible friends through working
in the service industry cause like you
have to have a backbone to be able to do
it oh my god do you have to have a
backbone I'm more worried about you if
you treat me with respect
I'm not your slave I work there for
minimum wage plus tips we live off to
put that in your brain and cement it
there forever let's all relax and stop
treating us like we're they
to do your bidding because we're not
don't be a dick
don't
[Music]